why do we do this okay
sometimes you're like that it's not
consistent with or representative of
what I'm calling any social violence
where I practice territoriality he is
and that would be fine and we were doing
leverage taking he's diamond but not
Khushi
[Music]
and I my way
chip chip chip not even close
so you misplace or okay so he's gonna
try that what what happened I don't try
to there's a lot of young energy okay so
what we're doing is checking out his
striking capacity if you don't have your
striking capacity check down strike
butter but we're checking out these
striking contestant and that's why he
has to go to the throw to get it so he's
doing the same thing and I'm gonna get
jammed or hit on my words or miss
altogether you got it so you don't go
here and try to do that strike you
tactical arena you're into throwing
tactical arena they don't coexist
go ahead okay so that's why me does his
[Music]
and then it keeps going that way don't
pull this keeps going that way you keep
boom box and you reverse it you get here
[Music]
don't reverse it keeps going
it comes bot it's going the other way
don't go this way
[Music]
just stop this but when you go here
whatever balance breakers you god you're
gonna push a bot onto this base so we're
not gonna worry about them right now
just do the cowboy yeah his head
so if you kind of just do the hostel out
here we're not trying any idea and
you're just trying to pull them up okay
that's what I want and that's what I
need what you are going to do the same
thing so once I have your stuff on your
okay and not going here and I go on the
arm
now
[Music]
that was a clock you see so he was
coming at me you see
so he's coming at me and I'm going to
heal DC and take the Twitter box that's
exactly and then you're gonna get the
same bot Alberta sushi platter so I'm
not going like this boom it's just very
small you see it is the same rule he
hits the Box foot it wasn't okay it's
just very small
[Music]
but from you summon your kami by YouTube
you stop the displacement so what are
you supposed to do not yet
not smack the out
don't come in so okay so he's pushy
I left the Armco my body is gonna do
cook you can't go back yet then his body
starts to tilt here we go
his body tilts their hips and projected
we're turning he's still going forward
because he turned because he tilted it's
not that he comes here and he bends his
box for me I went on the side and I
Chilton here tilted him
[Music]
this is